well being back another well a
convention is amazing and because this
is Disney there's like people that I'm
like oh my good it's Johnny Depp
it's so nice so nice and to be back here
with Harrison obviously it makes
everything feel that bit more special
it's a weird thing like when we came to
celebration I'd never been to a fan
convention before and so that was like
the beginning and then comic-con and
then this it's like each thing and
because we're like so close now
it's so nice feeling like all this
excitement is going to amount to
something very soon so even though we
had nothing
well except that amazing poster below
it's it's great and as it builds it's so
exciting there was John boyega there was
Oscar Isaac and Lupita who is in three
Disney films so to do even on stage like
a million times it's nice it's nice girl
power d23 is a chance for Disney to
really connect with fans to bring him in
on news to let them know how projects
are going and to really really give the
fans an opportunity to play an active
part in the big company d23 is
interesting because you know fans
normally don't get to partake in the
studio you know decisions or whatever
but d23 gives the fans the opportunity
to have a voice to be excited about
things to get exclusive looks and you
know Disney basically brought everything
so now you can get exclusive look so you
know this is the Star Wars movies two
spin-offs the Disney live-action films
and that's what did 23 years is for that
was for the fans
oh so today we went on stage Alan horn
was there Bob Iger JJ Abrams Lupita
Nyong'o Daisy Ridley Oscar Isaacs and
myself we all went on stage and said
hello to the fans and then I revealed an
exclusive d23 poster so I was awakened
first also and the fans got their poster
reach you to take home and to enjoy and
yeah so we on stage to say another to
the mall it was so fantastic oh yeah
there was a surprise guest by Harrison
Moore and yeah Harrison was there and he
came on and said hello to the fans as
well so yeah it was a great great great
time particularly when Harrison came out
and everyone's that I began and how
excited they are
you know and again it just puts puts me
back in touch with what a cultural
phenomenon this thing is it also was
very cool to see all the other movies
that are here and just how much
incredible stuff Disney's putting out
yeah well back at comic-con as well and
it's it's it's an amazing thing with
comic-con and with here when when they
finally realized that that Harrison's
going to be here and just what uh what
it means to the fans to see Han Solo
back and I think that once they actually
see him back in action in the film I
wouldn't be surprised if theaters erupt
innovations as well yeah it you know
because we've had to Ben we've had to be
so secretive about the whole thing and
so as the date approaches it's really
fun to know that soon the rest of the
world is going to get to enjoy the fun
that we've been having for such a long
time I mean this is my first experience
at any sort of convention of this nature
and so it was it was like everyone is so
pumped up you know to hear about the
films and it's so nice to be in a room
full of people who love what you do
already you know it's it's it's really
it was really exciting and and I got
goosebumps you know just hearing the
fervor coming through yeah it's been
really cool yeah I mean it's it's
obviously Disney has meant a lot to a
lot of people over the years and to be a
part of Disney and first of all you know
to have three films with the Disney is
really lovely and to just be a part of
those stories those iconic stories that
will that children are watching and are
going to grow up referencing is is
really it's just an honor it's
incredibly gratifying to go out into a
room of many thousands of people who
love this world that George live was
created I get to you know be part of
something that matters to me as much as
everyone on the floor so it was it was I
felt very lucky to be up on stage and in
many ways could easily have seen myself
in the crowd you know cheering along
with them so I'm very grateful well you
know Harrison is I mean it's almost like
cheating because you bring Harrison Ford
out and it's like what are they gonna
you know people are crazy but it was
it's something that is it's real and
they they love han Solo they love him as
han Solo and they should he's so
terrific and and mind-blowing Lee
wonderful in the movie and so it's it's
great to see a reaction of such a huge
number of people that we would have
every day on set internally you know
getting to work with him well I think
that in a way this movie is sort of a
bridge because it's it's taking things
that you know and it's hopefully showing
them in a way you don't expect but it's
all about telling a new story this is
the key to this movie is telling you
something that you haven't seen before
and don't know and the beauty of the
story is that the history of these
characters is the history we know from
the preceding film so it was a Rena
Lawrence Kasdan who wrote the script
with me we really focused on how do we
tell a story and incorporate what people
know in a way that won't feel like we're
just doing callbacks for the sake of it
that it's you know it's not about a you
know a best-of you know moment but it's
it's really about telling us a solid
story and we were very lucky to have the
whole cast do such an extraordinary job
you